[Music]
do you remember what happened
uh when during the battle
welcome to the dark side of the moon
gentlemen
aren't we supposed to be on top of the
mountain to win this thing
[Music]
our job is to separate the taliban
from the ordinary people
how do we do our jobs and stay safe
respect keeps us safe i wouldn't trade
this for anything
look at us band of brothers keep me in
your prayers okay
trust me babe i quit i love you i'm
gonna win by getting their hearts in my
eyes we want the hearts and minds and
they want our blood and guts
sorry pal but that's life at camp
keating
every time they take a pot shot at us
they're figuring us out and the big one
comes
all of us dialed in the talibans are
here
there's the big one saddle up everybody
follow that enemy in the wire
i'll hang back and provide cover
we need to retake this camp we don't
have any air support
the manpower our men are trapped up
there
our ammo deeper was 40 yards away
there's everything we need to stay in
this fight
let me do this
let's show them some love with the 120s
you're all right mate come on your arms
around me
you're not gonna die okay rpg
run for two
[Music]
we're taking this pitch back
[Music]
you